eher tiefe und bereits international
erfolgreiche gegenbeweis julian zigerli
ist auf zack
er hat besuch aus barcelona eine stoff
lieferantin stellt dem zürcher designer
ihre neuesten produkte vor
das futuristische gewebe wird der
zigerli kunde im sommer 2015 tragen
seine kleider sind wie er selbst frech
und unkonventionell mein liebling
ausmachen und es ist eine funktion und
funktionäre das stimmigste sei wichtig
dass das nicht einfach nur zwei 13
jährige arzt innerhalb 50 jährige schon
mit seiner diplom kollektion an der
hochschule der künste in berlin
verblüfft er das fachpublikum mit einer
weltneuheit zigerli kreiert einen hybrid
zwischen rucksack und mantel seit drei
jahren besitzt der 30 jährige sein
eigenes label
er ist designer und unternehmer
entscheidet bei der kreation und behält
das budget im auge und als chef
ich glaube ich mutter teresa gute
stimmung herrscht erinnern und ich wir
nicht den chef wie viel geld zahlt bis
gleich mit zelt und profitiere ich
natürlich fort eine lied war damit
schafft für praktikum machen oder was
einer und modernen aber möglich spiel
mit gern dass die kleinste vorhang
generation praktikum das junge
lebensgefühl der modebranche ohne seine
helfer gäbe es die bunte zigerli welt
nicht die kleidungsstücke entstehen nach
einem ganz eigenen baukastensystem das
mit bordwand ich sehr oft mit schafft
von exali de herr schreibt es infos im
internet von überall und erzieher nicht
ein einziger mini essentiell aber nicht
bruch für die kollektion dein eigenes
langsam user im letzten januar konnte
cad an der mailänder modewoche seine
visionen für den mann von heute
präsentieren
eingeladen vom großen giorgio armani
persönlich acht minuten show kostenpunkt
15 tausend franken
verschnaufpause in uster die eltern von
julian cd sind sein finanzielles
rückgrat
sie investieren gerne und viel in das
label ihres sohnes für die und ihre
kollektion familie der mode häuptling
will nicht bloß kleider machen sondern
welten kreieren zu jeder kollektion
entsteht ein film der das zigerli
lebensgefühl transportiert
haben
sogar hollywood schauspieler alan
cumming schlüpfte schon in einzige
outfit
er bewahrt sich seine eigenständigkeit
agiert mit leidenschaft und mobilisiert
geschickt sein kreatives umfeld das ist
das erfolgsrezept des jungen kreativen
ich hoffe alle freundschaften zu viele
freundinnen freunde und es ist schwer so
ein klub um zu unterstützen als die
wissen einfach wissen wie das so abläuft
und hat eine neue spitze
nach der show ist vor der show seine
nächste wichtige etappe im juni die
präsentation der sommerkollektion
zigerli bleibt auf zack